[Musique]
je suis vraiment désolé que cette vidéo
arrive en retard je crois que je suis
après tout le monde
mais ces vidéos ça fait un moment que je
suis dessus j'ai eu pas mal de
contretemps bref désolé
enfin la voilà je peine encore à croire
que la suite de breath of the wild est
été annoncé et c'est vraiment juste mais
incroyable comme je l'affirmé dans mon
trois théories sur zelda je suis un vrai
passionné vite zelda tous les jours je
bouquine hyrule histo mecs faut
qu't'arrêtes avec cette histoire de
bouquiner hyrule historia tous les jours
personne ne fait ça ouais d'accord
donc oui il ya héros dans la vidéo du
coup j'ai oublié de le préciser
comme vous le voyez je ne suis pas seul
vous allez voir une vidéo vraiment 100%
subjective et qu'ils aient travaillé
depuis la sortie du trailer mais auquel
j'avais eu beaucoup d'examens
bref encore désolé du retard c'est clair
qu'on a attendu mec bon bah on commence
où on attend que impa meurent de
vieillesse
[ __ ] aéro bon bref cette vidéo va être
compliqué je le sens à les génériques
[Musique]
bon à l'heure actuelle ce n'est plus
vraiment une théorie et même sans avoir
confirmation il était très facile de
s'en douter
ganondorf est de retour à notre plus
grande surprise effectivement la momie
qui se réveille à la fin du trailer est
bel et bien ganondorf l'ennemi juré du
royaume d'hyrule et de les lui à titre
personnel je trouve ça réellement
incroyable que ganondorf sont de retour
et cela va impliquer du lourd du très
lourd
déjà comment prouver pour certains que
nous sommes bel et bien en face à
ganondorf ce dernier passait d'une
chevelure rougeoyantes qui nous rappelle
très fortement le dernier design
appliqué à ganondorf dans hyrule
warriors ses bijoux guérido l'ornement
qu'ils possédent kind of time twilight
princess wind waker et j'en passe des
jeunes nous sommes face à un guéridon
enfin la peinture sur le meilleur
représentant canadien à cheval et avec
un trident swing encore plus la chose
bref c'est ganondorf dernièrement les
glyphes guirado présent dans le trailer
on affirmé de par leur traduction le
retour du seigneur du mal avec pour
signification le saut au ghana la
première théorie et la deuxième théorie
seront plus ou moins liés dans leur
histoire mais j'aimerais pour commencé
calmement réagira et faire une réflexion
sur le retour de ses tantes agoniste et
notamment par rapport à bressols the
wild premier du nom nous voyons
actuellement dans le trailer que le sou
retenant canon d'or est sur le point de
se briser une grande puissance
malveillantes émane du corps momifié et
je pense à titre personnel que cela fait
un moment que le saut est sur le point
de se briser
je dirais un peu plus de 100 ans
effectivement dans brasseur the wild le
boss de fin et ganon le fléau avec un
visuel très spectrale pour aller droit
au but je pense très sincèrement que
breath of the way nous proposait comme
ennemi une projection de ganondorf en
ganon idée accentuée par les
déclarations du roi
je cite le monstre retrouvera sa forme
originelle et s'abattra sur hyrule de
toute sa puissance
ganondorf dans prince of the world était
encore sous l'emprise du sceau
l'empêchant de pouvoir se mouvoir et
d'agir sa projection dans bresso elle
servait justement à pouvoir revenir et
massacrant tout le monde avoir le
terrain libre pour se libérer de son
saut et recouvré toute sa puissance
ce qui me fait penser ceci également et
que le roi affirme que c'est au sein
même du royaume d'hyrule que ganon le
fléau a vu le jour il ya bien des
siècles plusieurs choses sont
intéressantes là dedans mais pour le
moment un détail nous intéresse il est
souligné dans ses paroles que ganondorf
il y à 100 ans était déjà sous le
château d'hyrule a sommeillé je le
comprends comme ceux ci est justement la
salle où est enfermé ganondorf est
rempli de pics rocheux pic que nous
retrouvons autour du château lorsque le
fléau est réapparu il ya cent ans
de par la position des piques nous avons
l'impression qu'ils ont émané de la
hougue en indoor se trouvait sous le
château
ceci prouve pour moi son intérêt et sa
projection par le biais du saut qui
s'affaiblit de jour en jour alors oui
nous devons parler du temps ce n'est pas
montrer explicitement mais le fait que
ganondorf soit une momie n'est vraiment
pas anodin il se pourrait et cela en est
même certain
ganondorf moisi sous le château d'hyrule
scellé depuis plus de dix mille ans
pourquoi cela déjà nous pouvons faire le
rapprochement avec les moines chèque à
présent dans breath of the wild
ces derniers sont présents également
depuis cette période comme nous le
montre la légende présenté par him pas
de plus le choix de la momie souligne
l'ancienneté comme un pharaon dans son
tombeau
un code visuellement important enfin à
la peinture sur le mur avec une
représentation d'un ganondorf au plus
haut de sa forme nous montre l'évolution
du personnage mais également une mise en
garde de là où vous mettez les pieds
nous sommes dans le sanctuaire
renfermant ganondorf d'ailleurs les
dessins sur les murs ont la même
signification que la momification
l'ancienneté mais du coup si ganondorf
est toujours présent et ce depuis dix
mille ans que s'est il passé réellement
n'avait-il pas été vaincue en deux coups
de cuillère à pot normalement
[Musique]
effectivement nous sommes sur une fuite
de presse the wild
un jeu qui se déroulera après ce que
nous avons connu dans le premier opus
comme il nous l'a été déclaré néanmoins
paradoxalement ce sera un jeu qui
pourrait être intimement liée à ce qu'il
s'est passé avant breath of the whale
dix mille ans auparavant
je m'explique nous sommes obligés de
remémorer le passé notamment par la
présence de ganondorf sommeillant depuis
plus de dix mille ans à cause du saut en
parlant du soutien de par sa couleur la
forme des particules
nous ne pouvons nous empêcher de lier
ceci à la légende dit mme pas avec
l'ancien héros qui vaincus ganondorf
autrefois soit un élément de plus nous
reliant à cette période il se pourrait
et cela en est même certain que la main
retenant ganondorf soit celle du héros
de jadis permettant d'emprisonner le
démon cette idée est accentuée par le
fait que link semble intimement liés
dans le trailer au pouvoir retenant
ganondorf au point même de l'absorber ce
qui ferait probablement au gré de ses
pouvoirs le pouvoir de deux héros dans
le corps d'un seul l'idée me plaît mais
il n'y aura t'il par conflit temporel je
m'égare
mais tous ces détails m'empêche d'y voir
clair il manque des réponses dans
l'histoire et la légende présenté par
rim pa cette dernière nous affirme que
le héros et la princesse n'était pas
seul mais accompagné des gardiens et des
créatures divines et donc qu'ils ont
brillamment vaincu galant d'or sans
réelle difficulté
pourquoi kendor fait-il toujours envie
dix mille ans plus tard
et pourquoi avoir enterré les créatures
divines ainsi que les gardiens puisque
ils ont l'air très utile dans breath of
the wild
même après la défaite de ganon le fléau
ce que je veux dire c'est que him pas
elle même c'est que l'histoire de ganon
et de la famille d'hyrule est intimement
liés et que l'histoire se répète donc
encore et encore alors pourquoi avoir
mis de côté les créatures depuis tout ce
temps et surtout comment se fait-il kim
pas en sache autant sur l'histoire
d'hyrule et du retour incessant de ganon
que s'est il réellement passé au final
il y a dix mille ans c'est la question
que je me pose aujourd'hui
pourrait est seul en est même presque
sûr que tout ne sais pas si bien passée
que comme hymne pas nous le raconte
vaincre ganondorf n'est pas chose aisée
et si l'histoire est donc pas conclu dix
mille ans plus tard c'est que beaucoup
de non dits sont présents et signe un
second retour de ganondorf
j'attends des réponses concernant ce
breath of the wild 2 sur le passé de
breath of the wild
comme il est démontré dans ce trailer
inclure ganondorf dans l'histoire de
breath of the wild inclut forcément dû
l'or et comme hymne pas nous raconte la
légende nous avons l'impression qu'elle
même a connaissance de la malédiction
lancée par l'avatar du néant mais
recentrons nous j'aimerais accentuer une
autre partie du sujet le coût des
créatures divines et quelque chose de
réellement mystérieux dans breath of the
wild à plusieurs reprises on nous montre
que les créatures divines était bonne
pour le peuple qu'elle protégeait ces
derniers et vivait en harmonie avec ces
mêmes souligné avec les pilotes
oui cohabitent encore avec malgré l'acte
de ganon le fléau zelda à souhaite
d'ailleurs revoir var où tu as parce que
elle semble avoir un problème je dois me
rendre au domaine aura aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien comprendre pourquoi var
où tu as s'est immobilisée il faut que
je jette un coup d'oeil à son réservoir
d'eau
les créatures divines ont été conçus par
l'échec
il y a maintenant plus de dix mille ans
et ont servi à vaincre le fléau
cependant voka un déchet cas de breath
of the world nous amène une
problématique plutôt intéressante
après certains événements qui n'explique
pas en détail le peuple d'hyrule tripper
du peuple sheika à cause de leur
technologie très avancée et cheka se
divisèrent suite à cet événement créant
la branche des ieg a qui se sont
rebellés face au royaume prêtant
allégeance au fléau lés liga sont
aujourd'hui les ennemis d'hier eu leurs
ancêtres ont fait partie des créateurs
des créatures divines ainsi que des
gardiens
ces derniers savent reconnaître link en
un clin d'oeil savent ce qui le lie au
fléau
il est l'élu pour continuer ce que je
trouve très pertinent sont les dires du
roi au moment où il raconte l'histoire
d'il ya cent ans aline apparemment un
devin est venu prévenir le royaume que
ganon allait revenir une nouvelle fois
et qu'il remettrait au sein même du
royaume d'hyrule
son identité est un mystère mais ce
dernier laissait sous-entendre qu'un
moyen de contrer son retour était
présent dans les entrailles du château
des créatures divines ont alors été
découverte et quatre champions ont été
choisis pour les manipuler ainsi qu'une
armée de gardien vous ne voyez pas ici
quelque chose d'étrange le peuple
d'hyrule pris peur du peuple shake à
cause de leur technologie très avancée
et si le devin avait tendu un piège
effectivement ghana n'a pu revenir grâce
à la prise du pouvoir sur les gardiens
et les créatures divines ganon a réussi
à prendre possession de toutes les
machines chèque avec une simplicité
déconcertante
au point même de fusionner avec cette
technologie comme démontré dans
l'affrontement final
or breath of the wild l'utilisation des
gardiens lors de l'affrontement final
n'est qu'un bonus la véritable arme
pouvant défaire le fléau est bel et bien
link je le rappelle mais pourquoi avoir
enterré les créatures divines
il y a dix mille ans alors que ce sont
des engins si formidable et si au final
c'était tout le contraire
et si au final cela était dû à la
trahison des chèques a chassé par les
îliens qui ont pris peur de cette
nouvelle technologie avancée les gars
ont aujourd'hui prêté allégeance à ganon
oh et la technologie conçue par leurs
ancêtres ont permis à ce dernier de
pouvoir écraser le royaume d'hyrule
à son retour avec une grande simplicité
il est possible qu'au final c'est légal
endort fêtait pour le héros de l'époque
un moyen de pouvoir bloquer le mal à
tout jamais sans le tuer et donc qu'il
ne puisse revenir une nouvelle fois mais
et si la réponse à cette problématique
était bien plus sombre compense les igg
à la technologie chez cas la peur du
royaume les créatures divines enfouis
ganondorf ne semble pas être la seule
source du mal
formidable de l'amour
[Musique]
un vocal de pouvoir sacré irrité sous
sol
et celle arbitres m
[Musique]
il était pour moi évident d'en parler
qu'en est il de la timeline
j'entends déjà certains grincer des
dents mais il est vrai que c'est un
sujet à débat malgré l'officialisation
de cette dernière par nintendo notamment
par le biais d'hyrule historia et
skyward sword
la timeline est présente pour faire
plaisir aux fans et depuis un bon moment
en eau bassine que prince of the whale
ne fait pas partie de la timeline
déclaré par aonuma lui-même breath of
the wild a été placée à la fin de chaque
thème line sur le site officiel de
nintendo pour justement souligné senones
intérêt la fin de la timeline zelda mais
aujourd'hui je pense le contraire
effectivement aonuma est un petit malin
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il a tout
prémédité
pourquoi nous avoir caché le placement
de breath of the wild dans la timeline
jusqu'au point de le renier
car breath of the wild 2 peut nous
apporter les réponses qu'est ce qui me
fait penser ceci
premièrement le retour de ganondorf
faire revenir l'ennemi juré et ce sous
forme humaine de guérido n'est vraiment
pas anodin ganondorf est le symbole du
nord dans zelda la réincarnation de
l'avatar du néant le faire revenir
signifie qu'il ya derrière un background
historique
a contrario de ganon qui n'est qu'une
créatures des ténèbres
bref tout ça pour dire qu'avant en
bresse of the wild il y a une histoire
encore plus complète qu'on pense
maintenant tournons nous vers la
timeline il est encore beaucoup trop tôt
pour réellement affirmer sur où sera le
placement de breath of the wild et son
second opus il reste possible que
nintendo reste sur des jeux hors
timeline ou que nous sommes sur un
regroupement des trois branches au vu
des nombreuses références comme le
miroir des ombres et korhogo ou encore
la tenue des landes
rien qu'avec trois items nous avons déjà
une référence provenant de chaque
timeline cependant j'ai tout de même une
idée qui me fait fantasmer le détail clé
la peinture de ganondorf
cette image est réellement pleine de
sens un dessin pareil signifie tout
d'abord l'ancienneté du personnage et
notamment une mise en garde
mais le plus intéressant reste la
représentation du personnage
ganondorf est représenté sur son cheval
et il est armé d'un trident
dans l'histoire de zelda il ya seulement
deux jeux ou ganondorf est un cavalier
le premier et ocarina of time donc pas
très pertinent car il est présent dans
chaque femme line techniquement mais le
second jeu et twilight princess
c'est un indice important si ganondorf
est représenté sur un cheval c'est que
des gens dans l'univers de breath of the
wild l'ont connu en tant que cavalier
ocarina of time mais je pense beaucoup
beaucoup trop loin dans le temps en
revanche twilight princess et plus
proche et même dans le dessin lui même
qui rappelle beaucoup le ghana dorff de
tp
l'autre point et le trident rien de bien
fou le tri dans l arme de prédilection
de ganon peu importe la timeline
mais là où je veux en venir c'est que le
dessin représente ganondorf avec un
trident sur un cheval du jamais vu
ce dessin serait en fait une
représentation d'allah fois ganondorf
par le cheval et la forme humaine mais
aussi de ganon par rapport au trident
ce qui veut dire que nous sommes sur des
gens qui ont connu à la fois ganon mais
aussi ganondorf je crois que vous
commencez à comprendre
seul une branche nous présente à la fois
ganondorf et ganon la timeline de
l'enfant effectivement dans tp nous
sommes face à ganondorf capable de se
transformer en ganon mais également nous
le combattons sur un cheval dans force
wars adventures le zelda qui fait suite
à tp ganon est ressuscité et il est armé
de son trident
sans compter que force world adventures
est le dernier zelda de cette timeline
et qu'il est sous-entendu que ce dernier
reviendra et j'aurai ainsi sur ce détail
mais le ganondorf de cette timeline est
capable de se transformer à sa guise en
ganon contrairement à la timeline de la
défaite
nous nous sommes constamment face à la
bête ganon des noës de réelle
intelligence ou encore celle de l'adulte
ou ganon n'a jamais été présent
j'aimerais finir sur certains détails
effectivement l'ornementation les
doug est rude au rappel ganondorf de tp
les particules bleus peuvent rappeler me
donna ou encore pour certains le
craquement du coup dans le trailer leur
rappelle que jean tôt mais il ya encore
un détail très important dans la
timeline de l'enfance elle qui
correspondrait ganondorf possède une
blessure énormément importante et très
souligné dans cette branche
son torse seulement dans cette branche
ganondorf est blessé au torse et dans le
trailer
par roud ganondorf est maintenu et
scellé par le torse
son unique point faible depuis de tp
bien évidemment tout ceci reste une
interprétation personnelle
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en tout cas tout semble réellement lié
j'espère vraiment que la vidéo vous aura
plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me
le dire dans les commentaires à réagir
sur les théories me dire vos propres
avis justement âme vous abonner
justement sur youtube me suivre sur
twitter instagram
vous pouvez me soutenir via youtube bref
il ya plusieurs moyens à vous de choisir
papayou l'historienne bouquiner
aujourd'hui toi ben oui c'est vrai héros
sacré héros n'hésitez pas à les voir la
chaîne de 0,7
le père de l'infini c'est clairement mon
équivalent vivant alors oui les fans de
pop culture
et il vous a préparé aussi une grosse
vidéo sur breath of the wild 2 qui vaut
le détour
alors foncez pour devenir un explorateur
d'univers aller bref c'était argot rock
on va reparler de zelda très bientôt et
que le lionheart soit avec vous
[Musique]